oh that was great
[Music] oh it's like they're quite live in
Boston yeah
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are gonna do a movie reaction today
for The Equalizer time to be upfront about
a couple of things koi he has never seen The
Equalizer one I did see this one time when
I was a lot of that back then in 2014 needless
to say the only thing I kind of remember a
little bit of action other than that I really
don't know the plot anymore something about
protecting I I is it Dakota I forget who it
is some Johnson one of the Johnsons this will
be my first time re-watching this and I remember
walking out going it's good but I don't remember
it so and part of the thing I want to start
by the real rejects is like re-watching to
see if this movie's still good I have Armageddon
on my list like I have a few movies well you
don't know that so so that's my this is for
me my journey on that and this is Corey's
first time watching and if this goes well
we'll cover equalizer 2 both we have not seen
too long of an intro koi should they leave
a like they should leave a like because this
is about a quiet man living in Boston who
I assume is a mathematician because he equalizes
things perhaps he taught good with London
should they fall somewhere page five I was
on the patreon page where you can watch the
entire reaction start to finish you can watch
our resting faces sync up with us and then
we can see what they equalize I'm excited
to see if you like this movie I'm ready to
see what equalizes what is her name it's not
Johnson oh wait no I know which actress it
is shots is Man Apart I just remembered there's
a little girl but I just remember who the
actress was yeah I thought you meant the name
of the model today I thought there was like
a Johnson actress in here and and I'm realizing
it's a different little girl yeah there's
a different little girl in this movie yeah
oh wow this movie's deep 7 30 the most equal
of times everything balanced as they should
be left
notice these doors are not evenly shut equalize
them but it does it's an OCD freak I remember
it now
make your hairline very equal [Music] I gotta
cut this out it's not gonna stop screw you
guys the rest of the movie's gonna be that
two hours drama
I believe that this was a show first and then
they made the movies and then Queen Latifah's
in the show now and then they have a part
three coming up is it all one Universe like
John Wick I do not believe so okay how's it
going all right bro what you got that it's
tuna right whole grain gluten free okay condiments
it's a bone in the tuna
potatoes are a vegetable security guards you're
going to lose weight you got to test in one
week now you asked me to help you but if you're
not willing to apply yourself God damn that's
like a real life Denzel it's just in 10 lessons
this guy's taking out his board life while
making sure he loses weight I was something
once you better start being something you
could have projected my boredom under you
it's nice to see a movie in Boston that's
not about the Irish mob you fight them well
I don't remember who he fights actually his
mom I hope it is just a bunch of Scorsese
extras
this guy runs on Mark Wahlberg schedule gotta
pray gotta wake up gotta work out gotta sleep
I don't understand some of these meticulous
quirks I do think it's an OCD thing
Chloe Grace Moretz
yeah thank you oh 100 Johnson
he got that fish yet bought a little machine
for making demos I bet you're good it makes
you say that intuition cool let me know what
happens with that uh fish okay you picked
up on her occupation I think she might uh
be an architect yeah just saying she's probably
got a hyphen and her name you know what I'm
saying a little Terry Lynn action old man
tied to fish to the side of the boat had to
roll back to shore the fish bled in the water
Sharks game and ate the whole fish well it's
just kind of a waste isn't it oh that's clever
the old man met his greatest adversary just
when he thought that part of his life was
over he saw himself in the fish I like that
a lot I get what you're telling me movie
Russians
I don't think I've ever met a prostitute really
[Laughter] I'm from this
it's a pretty common job You're Gonna Leave
me to die I'm smoking inhalation I'm a buck
name how you gonna pull me out of a burning
building if you can't pull a tire 20 yards
hey don't doubt yourselves on doubt kills
get up doubt kills I like his little morsels
of wisdom come on [Applause] security guard
it's a smart movie because it really gets
you invested into his personality and mindset
yeah and he he cares for everybody yeah it's
really it is and we've met the fish and I
love the old man being like I'd follow a Trilogy
this old man hooking fish exactly it's not
gonna change he's not just like stoic and
or charming he's he's got like a full human
Personality yeah
Robert Robert reads books like this Bobby
sharper yeah okay different Vibes though Robbies
Bobs Roberts fair enough
okay it's not professional just tell me what
you think okay wow Alina oh on your wedding
figures no Mrs Robert at home no was there
ever once he's gonna break her heart just
broke my eye I hope you murdered her equalized
guy who thinks he's a knight in shining almond
only thing is he lives in a world where nights
don't exist anymore he reads a lot of apps
books convenient this list is it called the
equalizer's 100.
you'll see if you can clean things all right
whoa call this number I send you another one
better
[Laughter] he smells so confident that's great
it's like what reaction is he gonna give oh
man that was so much for badass today so in
control you could smile like that damn we're
like 20 minutes in her hasn't been an action
scene it's my favorite kind of action movies
I love the tension they're like letting build
like the lighting's doing so much heavy lifting
she's at the ICU at Shawmut someone beat her
up real good
damn this is a good movie yeah I don't remember
any of this it's too young ten years ago yeah
oh my goodness and she hit him back a guy
called sloppy so it's loving made an example
of her I burned one girl's face with batteries
2014 at the time when Russians were always
like bad guys in movies and stuff you mean
since 82.
that's myself [Laughter] I'm here about a
certain girl this girl she got a name her
name's Elena I understand it's like you're
an investment [Laughter] give you 9 800 dollars
Freedom Looking Americans think that you could
come into my place of business and just buy
whatever you want capitals nine thousand dollars
one month that's it one month
let's go
[Music]
oh he's got chills Goosebumps it's so cool
it's like Sherlock Holmes in it he's like
picking his weakness spots [Music]
nice tail oh
[Music]
oh cool
it's been past 16 seconds dude that shark
glare of his oh
you can see
oh 19 seconds Helena the girl you beat half
to death her life's gonna go on yours is gonna
have right here on this funky floor over ninety
eight hundred dollars consequences I remember
there being an action scene I don't remember
it being that violent that was like at all
so intense let me just go ahead and gut this
guy with a corkscrew of course yeah that was
gross oh I love the like the focal points
of weakness you saw across the room and then
like the timing of him marking it and then
like executing it yeah oh that was great this
guy's a great multitasker he'd run a wonderful
YouTube channel [Laughter] got the timing
down
testimon used to Leading that salty stuff
these are for you
I made the way oh
what happened hit it on something stupid [Laughter]
it's fascinating watching this back because
I remember it like fragment images like a
trailer in a way oh yeah like Memories like
that was familiar I think there's a like there's
an action scene here don't remember what it
what happens you know my heart rate went down
take me to the Madison
look at that guy about to go with this guy
I don't remember his name sure is a bad guy
a lot we figured two maybe three guys kill
them all that quickly none of our informants
heard about this going down security systems
hard drive was taken
drive me to my residence uh yeah wait a second
Mr Sunshine um what do I look like to you
chauffeur Town you're a [__] guest doing
a Boston accent I think uh something like
that I'm the one Mr Bush can calls in when
people like you I'm accountable now listen
pal I don't like your time with me Mr pushkin's
money for years I'm here to tell you what
to do nice is cool good villain he found his
equal I'm just excited David Harbor pre-news
room is in this movie my mom had a little
accident here last night there was a fire
I see okay looks like arson a little bit John
you know I got respect for your business you
understand why I'm compelled to make this
physio if I want to take over anything there'd
be nothing left to you people I hate you Russians
they're all crazy and you're arrogant more
reasonable man Mr Mooney I appreciate your
kindness It's refreshing and and lets me understand
that you're not smart enough to have done
this we pay you 15 to do business here the
additional 10 you steal we ignore we anticipated
as your people are such a cliche you think
you are coming down to me what I am who I
am is complicated what I am is easier I'm
a threat I alter outcomes oh geez oh damn
oh damn
oh
so much more brutal that was uh that was a
lot that's a lot right I uh whoa I feel like
David Harbor right now it's so unsettling
about it like violent about how uh aggressive
he was what the [__] what's that it's
a message says I'm here that guy must be so
tall [Laughter] oh that was intense it's a
great illustration of a villain because Denzel
is so efficient and clean and Swift and this
guy's just brutally messy this guy's like
a brawler and he's telling us he's giving
us a message yeah was there anything unusually
strange about slavi before he was murdered
did he mention the name perhaps agitated about
something who's this actress she's very cool
looking Daddy where we might find her sorry
all of our Associates Irish Italians Armenians
are all denying any knowledge or involvement
there's Armenians in Boston some they're all
in the mob recording movies whoever did this
specialized in I don't think it's someone
we've encountered before
it's an interesting structure we've barely
spent any time with Denzel in a while yeah
we don't really need to because they've established
them so well and then it's like charming and
then leave again and now they're really building
up the threat it's pretty clever it's different
it's more like a mini series it's more like
a show where you can live in an episode an
episode let's watch The Queen Latifah one
now I think it's going to be very similar
I'm sure she does such brutality she's playing
this role I like this red dragon shot good
call oh who puts the lotion on the skin but
they're making him like so animalistic and
like an alien threat with these wonky angles
is crazy there's like a hellish vibe to it
yeah especially with the satanic symbolism
on his body it's very subtle someone else's
clothes
what the [__]
uh uh see you pay on time no more problems
come on let's go to the banana hey officer
whoa I'd like to report a crime really call
9-1-1
when I got two corrupt cops right in front
of me how'd you get that [__] number it
wasn't hard yeah it was this
pay like everybody else how did he get that
those people you took the money from maybe
you should give it back would be the best
interest of everyone involved maybe our best
interest is to tie a cinder block around your
waist and throw you in the [__] Mystic
it's a good idea that's a terrible idea
foreign
Justice remember
I'm The Equalizer cleaning up the streets
of Boston yeah hurt more than the beaten sincerely
zero [__] no recollection of him cleaning
up anything else I was like I thought it was
just like bad guys
this is part of the movie now the lights come
back to the movie The Sun's shining like in
the first 10 minutes when
did you last talk I went to the hospital
yes ah nice man not black man she wanted to
know what happened to her no one saw her did
she like
damn this guy is scary terrified
oh it's so so off but I was born in killing
her just because she lied I think she lied
and because I mean leave a message to the
people that were friends with her that you
know they're gonna find that body they're
gonna find out they're gonna have people to
send messages
man all the angles is so intense like they
really it's interesting how they maintain
a level of Gore or like violence with both
our characters so the protagonist and antagonist
but one feels like a positive one feels like
a cool action movie The Other feels like super
Grim yeah that's a really good point and all
of his angles are so uncomfortable like whereas
all of Denzel's are cool there's a lot of
lurking in the shadows kind of and the frames
are really oh yeah you got the security job
now gain that weight back it's time I mean
the restaurant's probably making way more
money now frankly [Laughter] it's kind of
curious in this person walks in the front
door several minutes off the slot arrived
but never comes out
still shadowed and obscured that's how the
movie's lit it's actually accurate another
movie maybe not open there I just said oh
move perfect
your mother give me that ring Boston some
of the worst people it's okay Jenny
whoa crazy lighting damn
[Music]
there's some great visual language in a lot
of this
what a perfect store to work at for him
so excited to hear Denzel say Somerville it's
a Boston kid it's like I'm saying Eagle Rock
out here it's just a little town it's exciting
hey we saw the hammer
he put
he put inventory I love the way we need to
see it that's great I wonder if it was deleted
it's way more intense it works without scene
yeah because we're like was it probably more
violent and we did not score well with testosters
but our imagination is way more terrifying
than whatever actually not in this movie I
take it back this movie's very graphic we're
looking into a homicide it occurred two weeks
ago Russian restaurant oh yeah I heard about
it on TV I happen to be there that night are
you aware yeah you wouldn't be here if I wasn't
[Laughter] I was meeting a friend it was her
idea then I guess Sheila Saunders but she
won't be any health she wasn't there daughter
had a fever
don't you want to leave me your card officer
must have given them all out how'd you find
me I paid cash we didn't have a reservation
how'd you find me
we need to find we who
oh that was awesome what a great scene You're
such like a buildup yeah and it's not like
it's a finale there's just a dialogue confrontation
that was beautiful so that's why I killed
her to have a threat oh okay yeah get under
his skin that's how disposable everybody is
man that was intense more movies need that
scene where like the bad guy and the good
guy meet and it's intense yes and they go
to dinner and it's awesome I want to know
who he really is I want to know who he's working
for
still sits confidently by the window same
Diner they know he's going to be at our roll
no cheese please is it just you are we waiting
for someone else
fans if you really work the power lines down
there your hands wouldn't look like that I
know we got to be waiting for somebody else
[Laughter] respect oh I love it here's where
I could see him I'm gonna take a little walk
across the street me and you black Denali
here we go
no way yes
nice [Applause]
let's go no Witnesses [Music]
and he knows what the hell is this guy doing
[Music] [Laughter]
yes now he's got oh man that's good I [__]
love this movie [Laughter]
laughs if he bleeds man that book kill was
gnarly it doesn't like book stuff like the
Bourne movies and everything but I don't think
I've ever seen like a neck snap with a book
like into the table with that crunch
great Batman scene you know what this movie
manages to do really well where I feel like
a lot of action movies fail they managed to
have a main character who's so in control
and and you trust will handle [__] all
the time yet there's still manages to be tension
throughout yeah at no point am I not worried
but I know he's got normally there's no tension
because of that also the wiser 3 comes out
this year and I know I'm still invested it's
pretty crazy and you're right the juxtaposition
of like control versus brutality even though
he's brutal so interesting oh when did he
get cut who cut him first scrape himself by
accident and all that moving
he wouldn't go to his own house where did
he go
neither following the trail yes oh I love
this
plane ticket to Mexico two days ago he's not
going anywhere he's watching us find him or
I will bring people who care [Music]
so you have two apartments it's the dream
one to watch the other one checking in somebody
hit my house
cast is great what's her name ah [__]
it's really bothering me it'll come to me
it sounds like I'm reading the credits Melissa
Leo yes yeah I consult on a few things that's
it Susan I just need to know who this man
is tell me what's going on please
equalizing the streets I like that I've ever
done it cuts he says something like that they
cut out all the ziggers let's keep them cool
she couldn't count for his oh no not Robert
and not from something as trivial as a car
bomb Oh his name is actually Robert yeah okay
similar to the other oligarchs who jumped
in bed with funds everything gasoline weapons
girls you name it he's built an intricate
Network on both U.S coasts One Stop Shop your
friend here is who Pushkin sends when he's
got a problem real name Nikolai kitchen oh
that's where the photos I guess it's an explosion
and everything
no no found basically the sociopath for the
business we kept this it's like super clean
that was the actor's headshot I found them
yesterday suffocated testicles blown off and
shoved down their throats third one detective
Masters hasn't shown up for work in several
days oh he's a cop I didn't realize I didn't
realize that one day somebody does something
do something about it because you can because
it's who you are a pain in the sick that's
the theme I know a part of you guys she did
die okay how much recover that wasn't
when Rocky were you able to help him I don't
trust you Bill Pullman came for permission
yes yes what a good line let me read the clouds
when talking how can I use the clothes in
my disposal to win this one right on the Russians
now foreign
hope they all take place in Boston it's a
good question equalizing all the streets have
you ever seen the trailer for the third one
so I don't know
oh he's gonna make it look like he killed
himself and he plants in it all that's genius
there it is at the carbon monoxide [Music]
love it yes that's awesome you're about to
get equalized what does it even mean to equalize
equalized
horrible way to go I am a cop you [__]
I'll be back
this is made me question how many movies I've
seen David Harbor and if I didn't know it
was David Harper I think it's one of those
like career actors you're like all right yeah
who's in this movie have you seen The Newsroom
no okay that's excusable wow
wow how cool is a criminal it's profitable
who's this [__] piece of [__] new
guy
that was great oh [__] damn they did one
shot that was awesome it was so good guns
down lay down lay down with the hands behind
their back they'll do that won't they
indulge me Andre
it's not easy to do that before that was really
impressive yeah it's really believable yeah
I was a good cop [Music] do the right thing
good cups
fiction
Harper's great in this too I mean I imagine
he's always been a great actor yeah but he
gets more to do than I expect it's more than
suicide I thought it'd be like that sir it
was Boston in that too right Black Mass oh
yeah yeah he's gotten progressively better
at the accident I was that one scene through
me but I'm very impressed check this out
how did he get them all to get tied up got
him laying the floor at a time
you made things worse by looking for him it's
on you it's cool it's not just burning it
like most action movies my men will find him
good I got the pace Bono the fake beer
he's not coming back [Laughter] that was amazing
you can call your boss and tell him to shut
down his operation that's not much of an offer
that's the only one you're gonna get When
you pray for rain you got to deal with the
mud too cool I like that famous scholar lived
in Moscow he was a humanitarian and even though
he had five beautiful children he opened his
home to a sixth okay could have been pounded
by the system from an early age prone to violence
a lost cause stop me if you know this one
[Laughter] until the boy who had never felt
anything like being wanted or loved he finally
did one week later Intruders broke into the
man's house killed the man they said some
small things were stolen things a child might
steal okay I think the boy did it and he couldn't
bear the thought that this man this good man
would do that to him would throw him away
like a piece of land or
the man I killed your men they made their
decision I'm giving you the opportunity to
make yours Bank you're welcome
I promise someone that I love very much that
I would never go back to being that person
but for you I'm going to make an exception
what do you see when you look at me
will never be this cool that was so awesome
he made him emotional they had the heat scene
they got a lot
it's funny Senator I gotta get into politics
I mean
agent Mosley please heard you found some money
today check your personal email make sure
you're sitting down when you do [Laughter]
wow half a billion dollars cool we're in the
wrong business you know YouTube's just not
cutting it for the half these
good shot movies earned it they've earned
it it's earned it's definitely look away don't
watch it
foreign ER for A Man Apart the one with the
Johnson girl no man on fire is the man of
parts of Vin Diesel damn it the other ball
guys
dude he's just walking out of the explosion
[Music] wow they really threw down for this
well there's that setting on fire thing I
was talking about Brick by Brick but your
life for that rules from a call oh
unless you're here in 29.
Dad's all just got equalized all things balanced
you Glen it out when you see him shoot him
which way are we getting a Home Depot fight
sorry to spoil it for you but Chan's dream
location I remember any details about the
fight I've always wanted a Home Depot fight
oh
what the hell moved out of the way just step
to the side oh
you just lures him into that room one at a
time
when he hit him that was risky oh listen everybody
out of here don't leave anybody behind you
can use the service doors in the back okay
go only two people with the hostages I guess
they assumed they were just you know Home
Depot employees very clever Mr McCall I decided
to come and see you I'll be waiting for you
find the hostages
was this pretty John Wick I think it is some
of the same stunt people too
oh is that Barbed yeah oh what a way to go
yo he likes to kill yeah he likes to watch
oh
Jesus Christ damn
starting in a freaking Jason Voorhees this
is so intense oh no he's human he brought
a gun to a knife fight [Music] she's doing
Denzel the little pipe bomb what's it supposed
to go oh is he cauterizing the wound Maybe
nope oh Megan making a little doorknob Bob
oh he just got arrested a little doorknob
[Applause] you pushed him right into the oh
God [Music] I would love it if you actually
hit the water after all that
the big guys are always harder to take down
especially with mustaches
I can't even see what he's doing he's like
taking blades and just chop suey in him he's
pepper cutting them
no oh
ouch
yeah
oh
it's me Mr McCall that's Ralphie
I should not leave anybody behind who's gonna
try again beautiful
[Laughter] come on oh no no not the buddy
not his buddy he lost all that weight can
you make it to the breaker box 40 seconds
exactly
this is such a dark Warehouse
I wonder for the edit they planned this to
be 40 seconds too it's exactly 40 seconds
I think earlier was actually the 28 seconds
felt like about accurate I wonder if
okay [Applause]
oh damn no
[Applause]
did he know that guy was gonna be in that
room
was that nail gun nail got him in the rain
foreign
[Applause] [Music]
cool
great looking shots damn
oh
sexy when it rains you gotta be prepared for
the mud blood Bud
hardcore dude that was crazy now that guy
knows friends is a mercenary
you should be working security not me his
training makes much more sense and it's much
scarier now you said so many threatening things
this man can murder me
contextualizes every conversation we've ever
had I'm terrified of this man [Music]
he goes to Russia to take out the boss yeah
oh no way
I was thinking like like 40 minutes and like
what this battery takes him out here won't
they still just keep it I was going in my
head like is that what the sequel list they
just keep coming back from every bigger boss
yeah that's like the end of Blade he's going
to Moscow to take out the lead vampire
come to kill me yes what's he doing with the
light disorienting let's do the game from
my dad peace yeah
whoa
for the second movie was a lot of fun too
I hope so because this is great yeah I want
more equalizing so much more
and by the last few days I'm gonna run into
you yeah I'm reading now oh no when they giving
myself back at the hospital there was this
envelope my name on it almost ten thousand
dollars inside nine thousand eight hundred
roughly if someone else told me I could be
whoever I wanted to be Body Mind Spirit nice
remember you got your own thank you
and catch you around all right
oh my God they should do a spin-off with just
her focusing on her music career the whole
series but call it hit girl about making hits
hahaha
next I'll battle the sea now the sea man those
you see stories there's uh themes they're
all nautical
oh my God is he writing a book now The Invisible
Man this list is very topical to his goals
and I respect it
oh [__]
damn he's just a full-blown vigilante now
badass For Hire Denzel Craigslist vigilante
I thought it was not as good as equalizer
I see why they went with the one they did
I wonder what the original shows like
common two what come on gonna do it's too
late to start over the song made for this
I'm wondering yeah we're friends because he
did Southpaw yeah which is based on M's life
but as a as a boxer Jason Blumenthal is that
Jason Blum oh that's interesting yeah well
free blumhouse action horror would make sense
because that was brutal well if there's no
credits I mean if they're if Amazon is recommending
this watch The Mask it just means there's
no post credit no post credit well um I mean
we said a lot during the reaction but koi
take it away for your first time watching
what did you think uh that was whichever came
first inspired the hell out of the other with
John Wayne yeah I don't know which one came
first I'll look it up right now it was a hell
of a chicken
uh man she was rad um I loved that it was
um it trusted the audience to be ponderous
and also to be brutal and then go back and
forth I love the lighting I love the pacing
I loved it was like almost um over the top
of the lighting at first but then like it
set the tone of the movie really well I really
loved the framing there's a lot of shots of
the bad guy that are disorienting on purpose
that make you just uncomfortable and you don't
realize why you're so uncomfortable you just
have this like uh and uh I think that really
is beautifully juxtaposed with all the moving
shots and the emotionality of Denzel's character
because they cut to his eyes a lot and that
gives you you the like ability to like lean
into the character and I was saying at the
very beginning the you have to cast really
well to do the extreme close-ups they do I
didn't realize the theme of the movie was
gonna be like looking into the soul of Denzel
and he's got these great like shark eyes where
he does look lost not sad but lost and they
kept making that a a way to make you endeared
to him as opposed to the villains so the brutality
he was just brutal as a bad guys but like
it was the fire with fire thing that made
you love him I really this was a sensational
action thriller check this out what do we
got none of the movies influence each other
how they this phone only came out a few months
before is that crazy this is Armageddon Deep
Impact yeah isn't that crazy how like there's
somebody's there are similar lines to draw
wow like they're so different enough in an
execution in style but there's a lot of similarities
yeah between like Russian bad guys dead wife
pass coming back back into the field yeah
there's it's thinking I'm back but with the
equalizer it is funny how but he's like from
government in in John Wicks from like fantasy
Hitman yeah like that's a little bit more
they both have a fantasy world uh but this
is this is uh I mean they're very different
it wasn't cool to see them pair up oh Angela
Perry she's the Caspian stuff yeah this is
this is crazy yeah you would think that there
might be but they actually came out the same
year that's incredible that was so good I
can't believe those come out the same year
and now three is coming out the year four
came out for John Wick they've kept going
so good that's true except John works at four
but like I mean Denzel's been busy being awesome
well so is Keanu but that was that was so
good what'd you think for an accidental uh
not remembering I mean I really didn't remember
I I would the only time I remembered a couple
of things were was like oh yeah Chloe Grace
Moretz so I kept thinking is not Johnson Fanny
I can't get her name
this has been such a journey I'm like Ashley
Johnson from uh voiceovers and The Last of
Us she kind of looks like a Fanning what is
her name Dakota fan yeah Fanning's in A Man
Apart amazing man a man of fire my god there
was like an era of those kind of movies so
um a Man on Fire which um that's a fear such
a banger good choice that's another movie
about as in Denzel like trying to like who
I I kind of just got revenge on something
I think no I think she's kidnapped and he's
trying to save her oh okay but it's another
one with the him and a little white girl hey
let's watch all the dimensions
this second one does as well if this one does
well in the second one does well let's move
over to the saves White Girl Movement is in
that train movie they do with Chris Pine is
Chris Pine the little white he's a little
white girl and that's an eye I have not seen
that little white girl movie have you seen
I haven't seen it yeah I've seen pieces but
not tonight I've missed a lot of Denzel actually
I haven't seen like I was moved I haven't
seen safe house safe house I've seen half
of and loved it I was working in a movie theater
then so I like saw it in pieces where I'd
like walk in and be like Ryan Reynolds and
leaf there's another one called out of time
I've not seen that one the remake of taking
a Pelham One Two Three haven't seen that um
equalizer two uh equalizer two tinsel has
like there's a lot of like Denzel action movies
and then Liam took his jobs yeah but I feel
like Denzel really kept bringing because like
this is my memory told me it was just a straightforward
action movie which is brutal which it is it's
a straightforward action movie by plot but
the execution around it had a little more
Soul than I was expecting I recall at all
like I just I thought it was just a typical
like yeah he's I don't remember anything about
him like helping out the neighborhood which
feels a tad a tad like it didn't need to be
in this no that's how you like them otherwise
he's just killing people for that girl you
got to save the neighborhood it seemed like
if it was it didn't really serve the plot
overall it's happening from Boston I love
the neighborhood I like it I like that it's
here it didn't seem like it really was fully
fleshed out it was a bigger part of like him
him helping the guy as a security guard the
next step is to help help stop people for
like 15 minutes
maybe that's the show between Latifah well
I feel like the original show that this is
based on if I were to take a guess oh that
would be what what has happened and accelerates
into boss fights yeah like they needed a main
plot to focus on which was you know the whole
thing with Chloe Grace Moretz of the show
is like helping the town out yeah yeah I could
see that yeah I still like it in here it just
it kind of seemed like oh it was setting up
to become more and then it it doesn't because
we got busy because we got to go kill that
big bad yeah what was the bad guy's name did
we check was it Kieran is not he's not uh
his name didn't pop up uh so I I don't know
who it was okay but he was great he was great
really great formidable villain I did feel
like he lost some of his menacing threat towards
the finale the finale did feel the only time
I didn't love the pacing this is the third
act had a little bit of me being like okay
I've really enjoyed the intensity to this
point and now there's a couple times where
I was like this feels like they're drawing
out the suspense for the sake of it as opposed
to like with uh the drive the rest had I mean
yeah yeah that's true I would agree with that
because I I did I do wish that they kept the
villain truly menacing by the end to the point
where he did feel like a formidable match
yeah because that heat scene both of them
the one the one on the stairway is like one
of the best action threat scenes I've seen
yeah and then I enjoyed the dinner quite a
bit because that definitely was heat like
that was really great there's great acting
between this between the two of them they
know how to bounce off of each other and play
the cat and mouse game really well and I like
the pairing when you take that first scene
where they meet and then that second scene
it's really cool to watch the juxtaposition
and how the Dynamics have flipped around yeah
that's really cool what happened to Haley
what was that girl's name she was in um she
died no but she was also in that Uh Oh you
mean the actors like the actual actress I
thought you meant uh yeah it was very important
and very brutal yeah that was one of my favorite
shot scenes because they kept like cutting
outside the room to make you like Ah that's
like right in the neighborhood too yeah feel
it in the room no she was in that cowboy it
could happen in your neighborhood if you go
to selfie you might get strangled it should
happen anywhere man but no she uh she was
in that Chris Pratt cowboy movie uh Magnificent
Seven yeah and then I haven't seen her anything
since don't remember her or not yeah
I think it was yeah oh man he's great make
more movies I like Southpaw quite a bit but
I haven't seen I guess I haven't seen some
of his other work because southpaws I think
really slept on I haven't seen southpaw it's
crazy to see the trajectory of when you go
to training day which was a David ayerscript
and an Anton fuquan movie and then the directions
they've taken yeah Dave there has tried recapturing
the magic of training day yeah and Anton Fuqua
was like I'll make anything I'm an action
director I'm gonna make everything over there
which is not training you know he's just like
I'm an action director here on out I'm making
action movies and like Anton except for like
Southpaw I guess but there's like an element
oh there's actually yeah there's an action
element but like you're right there definitely
went other ways and David air was like End
of Watch and I'm gonna try to make training
days
gonna get a full stomach tattoo for me why
we don't know oh yeah that's right and no
one saw the movie but he got a tattoo for
real right I remember that that's right yeah
oh my God he's got a career man I'm sure he's
incredible but that's also him not trying
to make a David air movie David like that
action they both need to do good action movies
it would be cool to see them re-team again
yeah because of that but I I did well the
first movie I ever saw of Anton Fuqua was
a movie called The Replacement Killers not
The Replacements Keanu Reeves Replacements
is the football movie The Replacement Killers
is chow young fat I think that was his first
American lead film it's cool it's a cool ass
movie uh him and Mira servino and Michael
Rooker uh yeah that's a and that was the first
movie I think Anton fuco made that was like
a hit and then he did Training Day following
whoa so yeah sometimes you guys are like you've
not seen any movies yeah it's so funny if
you're like you haven't seen this it's like
hey look at the 4 000. there's like millions
of movies sorry we missed the one you love
a lot which is why we're watching it for you
but like there's so many movies um but yeah
I thought overall that this movie was so much
better than I expected it to be I didn't remember
being impressed by like I don't know I watch
movies a little more lazily back in the day
10 years ago can watch [__] right so watching
it now I I appreciate it so much more about
it that the the the the um the actual efforts
they made with unveiling and getting to know
who this character is whose name is Robert
oh who getting to know who Robert is throughout
the course of this film and underst and they
actually lean into the fact that you know
there's a part of him that wants to kill he's
a killer yeah you want to do it they don't
need some Spiel of like I know who you really
are Robert you're a killer like you don't
need to say that it was kind of neat to kind
of get that conversation from attraction from
through action and from the government person
who's like okay she's like you you this is
who you do yeah go be him go be that person
you were born to be you're a killer like she
doesn't say it but that's essentially that
dialogue that you get in every action movie
of this guy is you're a killer just admit
it you know and but they play into it with
the action when he watches them like he likes
to watch them die uh there's there is a violence
that he is drawn to and I think Chloe Grace
Moretz is actually I I didn't I didn't remember
until like moments before like oh yeah she's
in this movie uh I think Chloe Grace Moretz
is really good in this film it's kind of cool
how she can go from being like hit girl to
this person yeah the Innocence played as well
as her like insane violence place like some
people can't do the foul-mouthed you know
blah blah and then also scene innocence and
she nails that and that's not an easy role
to go from like you have to be so sympathetic
for her that you're like yeah you kill all
those people like he should put himself In
Harm's Way with this girl he knows from a
diner yeah and I also really like that everything
he did was so detail-oriented like the the
details he gives to help people the details
about the guy's hands the the details of looking
for weakness like his ability to curate a
room felt very plausible like they gave you
rules in this movie that I'm really excited
for it to be a series because I'm excited
to see him like use things so it was like
a Sherlock beats like Jackie Chan like how
will I use this weapon in this space but he
also uses it for like logic like the hands
thing that wasn't weaponized but it was showing
you how much he notices I love that yeah and
then the eyes he took my point yeah I was
gonna say I was thinking my head like when
he's done talking I'm gonna say Sherlock Holmes
he said exactly I think there was a warehouse
scene I've always wanted to see Jackie Chan
fight in a warehouse I had pretty sure he's
done that um has he yeah I'm sure he should
watch a Jackie Chan fish probably shoot a
lot of those actions he's done in a warehouse
in order to accomplish that I always think
about Jackie Chan in warehouses maybe I've
had a subconscious memory yeah I'm pretty
sure he's done that yeah the the action itself
was really well done and I I do I'm trying
to think of a point that we didn't say during
the reaction we talked a lot hopefully people
are okay with that I mean yeah there's some
like points to that had to be made um okay
so we covered the action drama casting the
Oh The Supporting Cast was really good too
A lot of the time a movie like this you'll
go I'm kind of bored when it's not Denzel
but not have that but I actually was really
endeared to the rest of the cast as well I
thought the villain was really great A lot
of times they botched the villain David Harbor
crushed as a supporting [__] David Harbor
at times have seemed a little bit like a little
melodramatic preachy when he was saying some
stuff about being a cop well oh I know what
what it was that I wanted to say was what
to your point about watching how he likes
to sort of mentor and instill good values
and stuff that makes it believable when he
is doing the Vigilante stuff because it's
not just self-serving in him wanting to be
you know like you buy into it that he's really
doing this out of a place of good yeah because
you see that he likes to still help people
out mentally first and emotionally and he
always gives him a chance to be better yeah
exactly uh so I think that's really that that
was a part that I thought really aided the
film and brought a little bit more to this
is what this movie really is is a lot of other
action movies we've seen just a little more
just more fleshed out and thought up yeah
than your typical action movie like it has
it's kind of like how I likened my experience
of them have you seen the movie Nobody [Music]
yeah yes I was like okay yeah there's a this
is a genre in and of itself there's a lot
of tropes but it's more fleshed out and that's
what I would say here is it is a lot of the
genre tropes that we've seen especially and
and like structurally but they mess with the
structure a little bit on where to focus and
they they actually developed the character
of of Robert Moore than you would normally
get they kind of do that all around yeah everyone
gets a little bit more time and every every
scene gets a little bit more patience yeah
even the Trope like abused girl that is gonna
go you know get Justice for that's a Trope
in and of itself but I actually wasn't bothered
by that Trope normally I am a little like
and this trip is a little Annoying and repetitive
but this time around it actually didn't bother
me because they did want to disgust you like
there were moments I was like repulsed like
some of the dialogue about it like they didn't
lean sometimes showing like actual assaults
yeah yeah but they let it be like really uncomfortable
like just showing the guy in the limo was
enough for me I was like oh okay like they
did a good job making your opposal without
making it gratuitous about that subplot because
I usually can't watch that stuff yeah exactly
that kind of stuff does bother me because
it does become like a Trope that I I'm sick
of seeing in movies and it's it's just like
they lean too much on it but they actually
really did a good job on painting the relationship
with Chloe Grace Moretz and Denzel Washington
uh in the early Parts like when they're walking
on the bridge and stuff like that like those
scenes I thought were really well done they
did such a great job before their first action
scene uh yeah you mentioned it was like 20
minutes in and like I also love that he had
a protocol like how they even the line of
dialogue establishes their relationship and
her breaking it and that escalating and all
those things and then yeah it's like 20 minutes
in until there's even action but there's been
so much like verbal action there's been so
much like tension yeah you know what I mean
good choice of music all around yep um I can't
wait to watch it so so excited I'm I can't
wait I don't don't look up the runs I didn't
know David Harper was in this one I'm excited
to see who's in the next one I don't know
Bill Pullman Melissa Leo like this cast was
stacked I'm excited to be like who's 2018
equalizer it was a surprisingly big cast considering
I researched David Harbor for interviews I
did not remember equalizer and I'm so excited
to see what like pops up for the next one
and it must have done well because the third
one's this year uh yeah they're really spread
apart the second one second when he has hair
look at the poster what oh now it's getting
real that's not my equalizer no look at that
man's hat I don't trust it oh looks like it
goes somewhere oh well don't read it oh no
equalizer one is five stars uh um out of 57
000 reviews crap out of 57 000 reviews it's
only four and a half so clearly clearly a
dip in quarterly as we learned with Kung Fu
Panda 2 which had a lesser rating it's clearly
a lesser film yeah watch us watch out this
is the one it's about family oh it's and fuqua's
back that's exciting I was always afraid I'm
pretty sure he's done all I'm pretty sure
he did equalizer three as well I just get
worried because when directors change it you
know sometimes oh he is back for that is he
back for equalizer three let's find out what's
he been doing
yeah he's bald he's back to being bald back
to the crit back to the baldness all right
guys that's exciting for all three that's
what I want to hear well guys what did you
think about The Equalizer I can't wait to
watch the second one and to do that we need
you to like subscribe comment let us know
which is your favorite of the equalizers and
if you're Denzel let us know if the third
one's any good yeah and if you're a Denzel
please I would not like to run into Home Depot
but you seem like a nice guy guys
falcoi and um hey let's do a patron of the
day shout out let's I know Adelia she's a
sweetie everyone knows Adelia so shout out
to Delia she is like The Equalizer of our
YouTube channel she really is actually she's
the perfect person to shout out for this Adelia
Chamberlain in case you didn't hear that depending
on the edit you are The Equalizer of the YouTube
Community you're everywhere you're a force
of good you're a force of being equal and
you're a force of being everywhere on these
internet streets making sure they're clean
and safe also for helping me figure out how
to run a Discord which is like equalizing
these streets can you tell us why he's named
equalizer let us know your subtext uh also
thank you for being a patron uh you're an
absolute Delight every interaction we've had
a new interneting has been wonderful and the
opposite of the violence that we just witnessed
matter in person once she was a total dear
she really is everywhere like I just did an
interview for a podcast for this other thing
and then I was talking with one of the people
who helped us running and they're like oh
do you know dealing in chamber let's just
start working with
she's always around and always helping and
a lot of times she used to do a lot of stuff
just rather kindness of her heart incredible
obviously that you finally got a job doing
it Delia love you so much and uh you've been
part of our patreon pretty much since the
beginnings and you've been in for years now
so thank you so much for being you talk to
you all soon [Music]